Dr James Carson the mid-1980s defined
these two types of games find out games
and infinite games
a finite game is known players fixed
rules and agreed upon objective
football baseball there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if
there's a winner necessarily they have
to be losers then you have infinite
gains infinite games are defined as
known and unknown players which means
new players can join anytime and you
don't necessarily know who all the other
players are I mean you definitely don't
know every Brewery in the world you know
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
turns out business is an infinite game